the left actually views
many aspects of our society notably the
criminal justice system it's just an
extension of slavery and jim crow aoc
made this point
aoc believes that that the prisons are
basically sort of modern-day slavery
and she thinks it ought to be a very
important goal of justice
to reduce the prison population if we
want to reduce violent crime
if we want to reduce the number of
people in our jails the answer
is to stop building more of them the
answer is to make sure that we actually
build more hospitals
we pay organizers we get people mental
health care
and overall health care employment etc
it's to support
communities not throw them away so
aoc wants to reduce the total prison
population there is crime
all over this country the
cities are being burned down left and
right
do you believe that we need fewer people
in prison
or more people in prison seems to me we
need more people we talk about we have
mass incarceration
not mass enough crime's going through
the roof
well no michael it's a terrible system
where people are going to jail for
having dime bags of marijuana first of
all that's not true
people are going to jail because they
get plea deals from much more
significant charges
but even beyond that as long as you've
got antifa and blm terrorizing the
streets as long as you've got crimes
spiking in the cities
why on earth would we want fewer people
in prison
if you want less crime you got to put
more criminals in the clink
aoc very focused on
justice we need to let the criminals out
of prison she says this would be justice
aoc does not seem so interested in
justice for her own family so she
tweeted
out just a couple days ago she goes just
over a week ago
my abuela fell ill i went to puerto rico
to see her
my first time in a year plus because of
covid this is her home
hurricane maria relief hasn't arrived
trump blocked money for puerto rico
people are forced to flee ancestral
homes and developers are taking them so
most of this is not true she says that
uh
hurricane maria relief hasn't arrived
that's not true we did send relief
trump blocked money for puerto rico no
he didn't that's not true what happened
is they sent money and then the corrupt
puerto rican officials
took the money and stole it but that's
not even my big problem with this tweet
here's my problem i'm looking at
abuela's house
i don't know if it's an apartment or a
house there's roof problems she's living
in squalor
i would estimate that to fix that roof
costs
i don't know like a thousand dollars or
something like that right it's a very
small roof
but let's say it's more let's say it's
ten thousand dollars to fix that roof
aoc is a wealthy woman she's a famous
wealthy politician she drives a tesla
she can't fix abuela's roof she that's
that's very wicked that's a that's an
evil thing to let your abuela
why do we have to use the term abuela by
the way does aoc not speak english
the term is grandmother i don't say you
know i was visiting my nonna
the other day you know i yes we went we
had a lovely christmas dinner
i just uh left my uncle's house and then
uh i drove over to
my mom as a house no we don't do that
because we're
americans and we speak english here so
she's going to let her
her abuela live in squalor
aoc drives a tesla i drive a honda i was
thinking about buying a nicer car
but the nicer car i was gonna buy would
have been about ten thousand dollars
more than the honda was
so i got ten thousand dollars lying
around because i didn't go buy the
i wasn't even gonna buy a tesla i was
just gonna buy like a slightly fancier
car
so i got i got that 10 grand lying
around i would like to fix abuela's roof
i know multiple other people here who
would like to fix abuela's roof
so aoc doesn't want to do it just please
someone send us abuela's address
so that we can fix it but of course aoc
should i want to do that she actually
realized too
that she got caught in this she goes oh
no abuela is fine so what that'll look
fine looks like she's living in squalor
no no it's just we just need trump needs
to do it trump huh
that guy's not praying that guy's not
going to be president again until august
if recent reports are to be believed i'm
joking i'm joking
i'm joking so
aoc laments this horrible situation for
her
abuela she uh then laments being a
first-generation immigrant
she tweeted out she says i'm a first
generation how dare you speak to me this
way
the problem with that statement is aoc
is not a first generation immigrant
actually jeremy pointed this out to me
aoc responded this way to matt
walsh on twitter and then jeremy pointed
out to me she said aoc is not a first
generation immigrant her father was born
in america
and her mother was born in an american
territory
aoc has been an american citizen uh
without any question of her being a
first-generation immigrant
words have meaning if we are to have
self-government words need to have
meaning
i write about this in my upcoming book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
available now for pre-order hey there
before you go make sure you ring that
bell you subscribe you like you get the
notifications
you can head on over to apple podcast
google play spotify
stitcher all those places subscribe to
the audio podcast we really appreciate
it you can leave a five-star review and
a what oh oh this thing are you oh this
is my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling lines
which is available now for pre-order
it's dropping on june 22nd you can get a
signed first edition copy of premiere
collectibles
this one i actually i'm glad i have the
physical copy so i can prove to you
this one unlike my first book has actual
words in it go check it out
see you next time
[Music]
you